قول اللجنه التابعه للمجلس الاعلى للدوله
والمتخصصه في فرز وقبولي ملفات الترشح
للمناصب السياديه في فرز الملفات التي
قدمت لها خلال الاسبوع الماضي حيث تنفرد
العربيه والحدث بمتابعه عمل اللجنه من
داخل مكاتبها اكثر من 400 ملف سيكون على
اللجنه مراجعتها بالكامل بعد ان ترشح
اصحابها لشغل المناصب السياديه المخوله
للمجلس تسميتها وابرزها رئيس ديوان
المحاسبه ومحافظ المصري في المركزي ورئيس
هيئه مكافحه الفساد ورئيس هيئه الرقابه
الاداريه
حتى تاخذ وقت لان عدد الملفات كبير خاصه
فيما يخص عضويات مكافحه الفساد وعضويه
المركزي وعضويه الاعلى المفوضيه العليا
للانتخابات بعد ان تتم عمليه الفرز يصوت
المجلس الاعلى لاختيار سبعه اسماء لكل
منصب يحولها مجلس النواب الاختيار ثلاثه
اسماء الذي يرجعها بدوره الى مجلس الدوله
لتسميه صاحب المنصب واعتماده بعد النجاح
في في
تنصيب النائب العام والمحكمه العليا وباقي
الخمسه ناقص السياديه باذن الله همم مع
همم الاخوه او الساده مجلس النواب
سيتم العمل معا باذن الله لانهاء هذا همم
الملف بالكامل تعقيدات واعراقيل كثيره
ترافق مراحل اختيار الشاغل المناصب
السياديه بدايه من التقسيمات القبليه
والجهويه لكل مرشح وصولا الى ربط نجاح
المجلسين في هذه العمليه بتوافقنا على
توحيد الحكوماتين مما يزيد الامر صعوبه
خصوصا بعد الخلافات الاخيره بين المجلسين
وحكومه الوحده الوطنيه
منير الاشهب ترابرس العربيه